SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN, I'LL RODA-GIL ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. ATKINS. BECKER BLAKE.
SPERM. BRADFORD. CABALLERO
CORTESE. DALLY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLAZER. GONZALEZ GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENJIVAR MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. THE QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY. PLEASE RISE. WE'LL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR DURAZZO. AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SENATOR
DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. YOU MEANS CLEAR THE
WAY IN THE LAKOTA LANGUAGE OF
THE NORTH AMERICAN PLAINS. GOD
OF SURPRISES, YOU CALL US FROM
THE NARROWNESS OF OUR TRADITIONS
TO NEW WAYS OF BEING HUMAN, FROM
THE CAPTIVITIES OF OUR CULTURE
TO CREATIVE WITNESS FOR JUSTICE,
FROM THE SMALLNESS OF OUR
HORIZONS TO THE MAGNIFICENCE OF
YOUR VISION, CLEAR THE WAY IN
US, YOUR PEOPLE, THAT WE MIGHT
INVITE OTHERS TO FREEDOM AND
RENEWED FAITH. GOD OF SURPRISES.
YOU CALL US FROM PREOCCUPATION
WITH OUR OWN HISTORIES AND HURTS
THE DAILY TASKS OF PEACEMAKING,
FROM PRIVILEGE AND PROTOCOL TO
PARTNERSHIP AND PILGRIMAGE, FROM
ISOLATION AND INSULARITY TO
INCLUSIVE COMMUNITY. CLEAR THE
WAY IN US, YOUR PEOPLE, THAT WE
MIGHT INVITE OTHERS TO WHOLENESS
AND INTEGRITY. HOLY TRANSFORMING
SPIRIT YOU CALL US FROM FEAR TO
FAITHFULNESS, FROM CLUTTER TO
CLARITY, FROM A DESIRE TO
CONTROL TO DEEPER TRUST, FROM
THE REFUSAL TO LOVE TO A
READINESS TO RISK. CLEAR THE WAY
IN US, YOUR PEOPLE, THAT WE
MIGHT ALL KNOW THE BEAUTY AND
THE POWER OF SPREADING YOUR GOOD
NEWS OF LOVE. AMEN IN. MEMBERS,
PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES. AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. MEMBERS WHO ARE NOW MOVING
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AT
THIS POINT, I WOULD. I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE JEREMY BLACKSHEAR, THE
HUSBAND OF SENATOR BLAKE SPEER,
UP IN THE GALLERY. WELCOME TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
.
NOW MOVING INTO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED FROM THE MAJORITY
LEADER'S DESK. THANK YOU. IT'S
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE DOCTOR
MARQUITA HÌ QUIRK-SILVA, WHO IS
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA. DOCTOR VÀ IS A
LIFELONG NURSE FROM SAN DIEGO
WHO PRIMARILY WORKS IN EMERGENCY
ROOM SETTINGS. THE DOCTOR IS
JOINING US TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF
NURSES ASSOCIATION. I'D SAY IN
RECOGNITION TO NATIONAL NURSES
WEEK. AND I'M HONORED TO DO THIS
AS A SON AND OF A NURSE AND AN
UNCLE OF TWO NURSES. THIS WEEK
WE CELEBRATE THE VITAL ROLE THAT
NURSES PLAY IN THE TRANSFORMING
HEALTH CARE AROUND THE WORLD.
DOCTOR AND MY MOTHER AND OTHERS
AND MY FAMILY HAS STATED, ARE
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING PATIENTS
CARE. THERE ARE OVER 5 MILLION
REGISTERED NURSES ACROSS AMERICA
IN MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
LOCATED HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR THE
VALUABLE WORK THAT YOU DO, AND
WE WISH YOU A CONTINUED SUCCESS
IN THE YEARS TO COME. LET'S
WELCOME HER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WELCOME
TO THE STATE SENATE
.
IF ANY OTHER MEMBER WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE GROUP PHOTO,
NOW IS THE TIME
.
MEMBERS. WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'LL TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTION. OUT OF ORDER TODAY.
FILE ITEM 96, SCR ONE FOR AFTER
ADOPTION OF THE RESOLUTION WILL
RETURN TO PRIVILEGE OF THE FLOOR
FOR THE AUTHOR TO INTRODUCE
GUEST. SENATOR RUBIO, SHE'S
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 144
BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE TO THE
TO THE DAY OF THE TEACHER.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE FLOOR, TODAY, I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT SCR 144, WHICH
COMMEMORATES MAY 8TH, 2024, AS
DAY OF THE TEACHER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE AND HONOR TEACHERS
FOR THEIR CONTINUOUS DEDICATION
AND RESILIENCE TO PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS WITH THE BEST CARE AND
EDUCATION. TEACHERS HAVE A
LASTING IMPACT ON OUR STUDENTS
AS THEY ARE GIVEN THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF FORMING THE
MINDS OF OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE
AND GENERATIONS TO COME. THEY
ARE NOT JUST EDUCATORS, THEIR
ROLE GOES BEYOND THE CLASSROOM.
THANK YOU. THEY ARE MENTORS,
COUNSELORS, AND SO MUCH MORE. AS
AN EDUCATOR FOR ALMOST 20 YEARS,
MYSELF, I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND
THE PASSION AND CARE THEY BRING
TO THEIR CLASSROOMS AND EVERY
STUDENT THEY TOUCH. IT IS A
PROFESSION OF TREMENDOUS
IMPORTANCE, ESPECIALLY THIS
CURRENT CLIMATE IN WHICH THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND OUR
NATION IS FACING A TEACHER
SHORTAGE, ACCORDING TO THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION, THE
STATE IS FACING A TEACHER
SHORTAGE WITH MORE THAN 10,000
VACANCIES STATEWIDE SHOWING A
DIRE NEED TO RETAIN TEACHERS.
THIS SHORTAGE LEADS TO MORE
PRESSURE AND RESPONSIBILITY ON
TEACHERS AS THEIR CLASS SIZES
BECOME LARGER, RESULTING IN MORE
SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS AND THE
POSSIBILITY OF SOME OF THEM
FALLING THROUGH THE CRACKS. AS A
TEACHER, AS I STATED, I REMEMBER
HAVING 18 TO 20 STUDENTS IN MY
CLASS AND FROM ONE YEAR TO THE
NEXT, IT GREW TO 34 STUDENTS IN
THE CLASSROOM, WHICH MADE IT
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO HELP THOSE
THAT WERE STRUGGLING. SO TODAY,
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THE WORK THAT THEY
DO, THE SACRIFICES THAT THEY
MAKE, NOT ONLY IN THE CLASSROOM,
BUT BEFORE SCHOOL, DURING
RECESS, LUNCH, AFTER SCHOOL,
EVERY MINUTE OF THE DAY. NOT
ONLY DO THEY SACRIFICE THEIR
PERSONAL TIME, TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES, BUT ALSO THEIR
FAMILY TIME. AS I KNOW OUR
TEACHERS ARE ALWAYS OUT THERE
SHOPPING FOR MATERIALS AND HOW
TO MAKE CLASS EXPERIENCE BETTER
FOR OUR STUDENTS. CGRTS. AND NOT
TO MENTION ALL THE HOURS THEY
PUT IN AT THE END OF THE YEAR
WITH REPORT CARDS AND EVERYTHING
THAT THEY HAVE TO DO TO HELP
CLOSE OUT THE YEAR. SO IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE STATE INVESTS
TODAY IN PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
TEACHERS, TO ENCOURAGE THEM TO
REMAIN IN THE CLASSROOM. LET US
TAKE THE TIME TODAY TO
APPRECIATE ALL OF OUR TEACHERS
WHO ARE EVERYDAY HEROES THAT
DEDICATED THEIR LIVES TO
EDUCATING OUR CHILDREN. SO WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE ON SCR 144. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM? SENATOR LEHRER THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF THE RESOLUTION, BUT I THOUGHT
I WOULD PUT A, AN INTERESTING
SITUATIONAL MOMENT TO THAT
RESOLUTION. I WENT TO MY HIGH
SCHOOL REUNION, AND I WANTED TO
HELP THEM SET UP THE ROOM, AND
THEY SAID, WE CAN'T DO IT YET.
THERE'S THIS GROUP THAT'S
ALREADY IN THERE, AND I GO AND
SEE WHAT THE GROUP IS, AND IT IS
STUDENTS FROM THE HIGH SCHOOL
WHERE MY FATHER TAUGHT FOR THE
20 YEARS HE TAUGHT THERE. SO I
IMMEDIATELY CRASHED THE PARTY
AND BECAME AN INSTANT CELEBRITY.
IT WAS LIKE, THIS IS MR. LAIRD'S
KID, AND AS I TALKED TO PEOPLE,
SOMEBODY SAID, OH, HE TAUGHT ME
HOW TO SWIM. SOMEBODY ELSE SAID,
I WAS ABOUT TO FAIL A TEST, AND
HE TOOK ME OUT IN THE HALLWAY
AND HE GAVE ME A PEP TALK, THERE
WAS SOMEBODY ELSE THAT SAID, OH,
YES, HE COACHED WINSTON HICKOX,
WHO SOME OF YOU KNOW, ON THE
HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL TEAM, AND
HE BECAME A CABINET SECRETARY
FOR THE STATE AND THAT'S A BIG
DEAL. AND I DID NOT TELL HER
WHAT I WAS DOING AND HAD DONE
THAT BECAUSE FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN YEARS, I WAS MY DAD'S SON.
AND WINSTON HICKOX EVEN TOLD ME
I GOT TO SACRAMENTO FIRST
BECAUSE OF YOUR DAD. AND I SAID,
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLY TRUE? AND
HE SAID, WELL, I GOT A
BASKETBALL SCHOLARSHIP TO SAC
STATE. SO THE RESOLUTION THAT
WAS JUST SPOKEN TO IS ABOUT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
TEACHERS THAT ARE JUST LIKE
THAT, THAT MAKE A COMPLETE
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF THE
KIDS THEY TOUCH, AND THEY MAKE
FINANCIAL SACRIFICE REYES TIME
SACRIFICES TO MAKE THAT
DIFFERENCE IN PEOPLE'S LIVES. SO
I STRONGLY SUPPORT IT. SCR 144
THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEMS? SEN RUBIO, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? NO THANK YOU. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM 96. ALAN A ALVARADO GIL A
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE HURTADO.
AYE. JONES. AYE LAIRD. AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PADILLA. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE MCGUIRE.
MIN PADILLA. SKINNER. AYE. AYES
36. NOES ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. NOW, MEMBERS, WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO PRIVILEGE
OF THE FLOOR. SENATOR RUBIO, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS OF THIS
BODY TODAY GIVES ME GREAT
PLEASURE TO PRESENT A RESOLUTION
. THÀNH, I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE
OUR CTA PRESIDENT. I'M HERE.
JOINING US IS PRESIDENT DAVID
GOLDBERG FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. DAVID HAS
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN COMMUNITY
STUDIES FROM FROM THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA, SANTA CRUZ, AND
ALSO EARNED HIS TEACHER
CREDENTIAL THROUGH THE INTERN
PROGRAM AT LAUSD. HIS FAMILY HAS
DEEP ROOTS IN PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND ADVOCACY. HIS GRANDMOTHER
WENT ON STRIKE FOR WEEKS, FOR
WEEKS THE YEAR HE BEFORE HE WAS
BORN. THAT STRIKE LED TO THE
FOUNDING OF UTLA, AND CTA WOULD
LATER FIGHT FOR THE RIGHT OF ALL
TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN. DAVID
HAS BEEN AN EDUCATOR SINCE 1997
AND IS A LONGTIME ADVOCATE FOR
STRONG PUBLIC SCHOOLS. HE IS
PASSIONATE ABOUT ORGANIZING AND
WINNING A FUTURE FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION, WHERE EVERY STUDENT
HAS THE RESOURCES THEY NEED AND
DESERVE. DAVID ALSO HAS LED
EFFORTS IN ESTABLISHING
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE, GUIDING LOCAL EDUCATORS
ASSOCIATIONS IN THEIR WORK TO
CREATE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK HIM
PERSONALLY AND ON BEHALF OF OUR
BODY HERE AND TEACHERS
EVERYWHERE WHO ARE WILLING TO
FIGHT FOR OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION AND TO GUIDE THEM
TOWARDS A BRIGHTER FUTURE.
MEMBERS, PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME
DAVID. THANK YOU. WELCOME TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
IF THERE ARE OTHER MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO JOIN IN ON THE
PHOTO, THAT NOW IS THE TIME
.
OUR MEMBERS. WE'RE MOVING ON.
MESSAGE FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED RED MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ, AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. NOW IS THE TIME. IF
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
SOMETHING. SENATOR CABALLERO.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST THAT FILE
ITEM NUMBER 123 SB 1369 BE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
SENATOR BLAKESBERG. THANK YOU. I
WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE ITEM SB
1156 FROM CONSENT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. THE DESK WILL NOTE.
NOW MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WE'RE MOVING TO SECOND READING
FILE.IT ONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL 1243. NOW WE'RE
AT THE POINT OF GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. WE HAVE TWO ITEMS,
TWO APPOINTED APPOINTMENTS. FILE
ITEM TWO. SENATOR CLARITY'S
PREPARED, I AM SECRETARY. YEAH
SENATOR LEHRER, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF THE
FOLLOWING APPOINTMENTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. RONALD
BLOOMFIELD AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
JASON JOHNSON AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DIVISION OF ADULT PAROLE
OPERATIONS. AND AMY CASILLAS AS
DIRECTOR FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. THE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL 17TH,
ALL ON A50 VOTE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE APPOINTMENTS HEARING?
SEEING NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN AYE. I'LL
RODA-GIL AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. AYE BECKER.
AYE. BLAKE. SPURR. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE GROVE. HURTADO.
AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE.
LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN. NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO OCHOA. AYE. PADILLA
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO. AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER.
AYE. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB.
AYE WIENER. AYE. WILK PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GROFF
MCGUIRE. MEN. NILA. AYE PADILLA.
WILK AYE. ISE 36. NO. ZERO. THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. NOW
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM FOUR.
SENATOR LEHRER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. FILE ITEM
FOUR IS THE CONFIRMATION OF KAT
ANDERSON FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
OFF-HIGHWAY MOTOR VEHICLE
RECREATION COMMISSION. SHE IS AN
ATTORNEY. SHE'S PRESIDENT OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO RECREATION AND
PARKS COMMISSION. SHE WAS
UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL 24TH. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS APPOINTMENT?
HEARING? SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COLIN.
AYE. AURORA. GIL. AYE ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE.
DODD. AYE. TORRAZZO EGGMAN.
TORRAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN. AYE
GLASER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO. AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE
MENJIVAR. AYE. MEN. NEWMAN AYE.
NGUYEN. AYE NEELAM. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
GROVE MCGUIRE. MIN. PADILLA
SKINNER. AYE AYES 36. NOES ZERO.
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
NOW. MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
SENATE. THIRD READING. WE HAVE
THREE ITEMS. FIRST UP IS FILE
ITEM 19 BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATOR NEWMAN, ARE YOU PREPARED
? SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
JOINT RESOLUTION 13 BY SENATOR
NEWMAN, RELATIVE TO THE NAVY
NORTH HANGAR FIRE. SENATOR
NEWMAN. AYE. THANK YOU. EXCUSE
ME. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
AM PLEASED TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT SCR 13.
THIS SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION
URGES THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
AND PRESIDENT BIDEN TO
APPROPRIATE $100 MILLION IN
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO ADDRESS
THE ONGOING IMPACTS ON PUBLIC
HEALTH, THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE
LOCAL ECONOMY AS A RESULT OF THE
DAMAGE AND FALLOUT CAUSED BY THE
RECENT FIRE AT THE FORMER MARINE
CORPS AIR STATION IN THE CITY OF
TUSTIN, AND ALSO CALLS ON THE
PRESIDENT TO DECLARE A FORMAL
EMERGENCY IN RESPONSE TO THE
ONGOING IMPACTS OF THAT FIRE. ON
NOVEMBER 7TH OF LAST YEAR, A
MASSIVE FIRE OF UNKNOWN ORIGIN
DESTROYED DESTROYED ONE OF THE
TWO GIANT HISTORIC BLIMP HANGARS
AT THE FORMER MARINE CORPS AIR
STATION IN THE CITY OF TUSTIN.
THE FIRE SMOLDERED CONTINUOUSLY
FOR 24 DAYS, WITH AIRBORNE
DEBRIS FROM THE HANGARS,
INTERIOR WIRING, AND INSULATION
CARRYING INTO TUSTIN INTERIOR
AND DIRECTLY AFFECTING MORE THAN
1500 HOMES, 29 LOCAL SCHOOLS AND
OVER 14,000 TUSTIN RESIDENTS.
ALMOST SIX MONTHS IN, THE
FALLOUT FROM THE FIRE CONTINUES
TO BE A SOURCE OF FRUSTRATION
AND CONCERN WITHIN THE
COMMUNITY, AND IT HAS LEFT THIS
RELATIVELY SMALL COMMUNITY WITH
UNPRECEDENTED FISCAL BURDENS. SO
FAR, TUSTIN HAS INCURRED OVER
$80 MILLION IN DIRECT COSTS
RELATED TO THE CLEANUP. WITH
THESE EMERGENCY EXPENSES NOW
HAVING EXCEEDED 100% OF THE
CITY'S ANNUAL BUDGET FOR THE
CURRENT FISCAL YEAR, THE
DEPARTMENT OF THE NAVY HAS BEEN
A GOOD PARTNER SO FAR, BUT THE
SCALE AND EXPENSE OF THE
CLEANUP, ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
THE CITY'S LIMITED RESOURCES,
SPEAKS TO THE NEED FOR
FORMALIZING THE REQUESTED
FEDERAL SUPPORT. SCR 13 URGES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MEET
ITS OBLIGATIONS IN RELATION TO
THIS FORMER MILITARY BASE AND TO
SUPPORT THE PRESSING NEEDS
CREATED BY THE NORTH HANGAR
FIRE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR. I VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM? HEARING. SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ELLEN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR.
AYE. MINH NEWMAN. AYE. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO. AYE. OCHOA AYE.
PODIUM. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE.
SKINNER AYE. SMILED. CUEVAS.
AYE. STERN AYE. UMBERG. AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBER. EGGMAN. AYE GROVE.
MCGUIRE. MIN PADILLA. AYES 36.
NOES ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
43 BY SENATOR CORTEZ. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU MAY
READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 139 BY SENATOR
CORTEZ. RELATIVE TO CALIFORNIA
MUSEUMS MONTH. SENATOR CORTEZ.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SCR 139 DECLARES MAY
OF 2024 AS CALIFORNIA MUSEUMS
MONTH. THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
MUSEUMS AS CIVIC AND EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS, AND IT'S PROUDLY
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MUSEUMS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO OVER 1500
MUSEUMS, WHICH OF COURSE INCLUDE
ART MUSEUMS, ZOOS, SCIENCE
CENTERS, BOTANICAL GARDENS,
CULTURAL CENTERS, AND MORE. OUR
MUSEUMS SERVE 22 MILLION
VISITORS ANNUALLY, INCLUDING 2
MILLION SCHOOL CHILDREN. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT VISITS TO
MUSEUMS HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT
ON THE ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
DEVELOPMENT OF CHILDREN AND THE
WELL-BEING OF ADULTS. MUSEUMS
FOSTER GROWTH AND KNOWLEDGE,
UNDERSTANDING AND APPRECIATION
OF THE HUMANITIES, SCIENCES,
ARTS, AND THE NATURAL WORLD.
MUSEUMS HAVE THE POWER TO
INSPIRE FUTURE GENERATIONS OF
SCIENTISTS, ARTISTS,
POLITICIANS, HISTORIANS, AND
ENTREPRENEURS. IN ADDITION TO
BEING EDUCATIONAL ASSETS FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. MUSEUMS IN THIS
STATE HAVE A $6.5 BILLION IMPACT
ON OUR ECONOMY AND SUPPORT
80,000 JOBS IN MY DISTRICT
ALONE, I HAVE THE HONOR OF
REPRESENTING MUSEUMS LIKE THE
TECH INTERACTIVE, THE CHILDREN'S
DISCOVERY MUSEUM, THE SAN JOSE
MUSEUM OF ART, THE JAPANESE
AMERICAN MUSEUM OF SAN JOSE, AND
EVEN THE SAN JOSE MUSEUM OF
QUILTS AND TEXTILES, AMONG
OTHERS. HERE OF COURSE, WE HAVE
THE PRIVILEGE TO BE SURROUNDED
BY MUSEUMS, AS I THINK MOST OF
US GREW UP GOING TO MUSEUMS
OURSELVES. I KNOW MANY OF US
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE AND THE
GOOD TIME TO BRING OUR OWN
CHILDREN TO MUSEUMS OR
GRANDCHILDREN. I HAVE MY
FAVORITES, MAYBE TOO MANY TO
LIST, AND I'M SURE YOU DO AS
WELL. AND I THINK EACH AND EVERY
ONE OF US HERE, REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, HAS
TAKEN AWAY SOMETHING OURSELVES
FROM A MUSEUM THAT'S BECOME PART
OF OUR OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
PART OF OUR OWN VALUES. SO I
ENCOURAGE ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
TO ENCOURAGE OTHER CALIFORNIANS
TO VISIT A MUSEUM THIS MONTH AND
CELEBRATE THE MANY CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT MUSEUMS ADD TO THE
WELL-BEING OF THE STATE. AND
THUS, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING AND
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION, WE DON'T.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE. ASHBY. AYE AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER. AYE BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLY AYE. DODD AYE. DURAZZO.
AYE. EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MINGE AYE.
MAIN. NEWMAN. AYE NGUYEN. AYE.
NILO. AYE. OKOBO HYPODERM.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYES 36.
NOS ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
NOW. MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM 64. SENATOR UMBERG.
HE'S PREPARED. SECRETARY, YOU
MAY READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 119 BY SENATOR
UMBERG. RELATIVE TO NATIONAL
FENTANYL AWARENESS.
DAY. SENATOR
UMBERG, THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 119 RECOGNIZING
TUESDAY, MAY 7TH, AS NATIONAL
FENTANYL AWARENESS DAY AS A
VOLUNTEER IN DRUG COURTS. AS THE
FORMER DEPUTY DRUG CZAR, FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR, BOARD MEMBER FOR THE
GROUP CALLED ALL RISE. I'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK IN DRUG
POLICY AND SEE FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACTS OF SUBSTANCE ABUSE FOR
THE LAST COUPLE OF DECADES, THE
IMPACTS OF FENTANYL ARE WORSE
THAN MOST ANY OTHER DRUG THAT
WE'VE KNOWN IN THE PAST.
FENTANYL OVERDOSES ARE POISONING
ARE BECOMING A GROWING THREAT TO
OUR NATION, QUICKLY BECOMING ONE
OF OUR TOP PUBLIC HEALTH CARE
CONCERNS. IN THE 12 MONTHS
ENDING IN JUNE OF 2023, OVER
75,000 PEOPLE DIED OF FENTANYL
OVERDOSES OR POISONING.
CALIFORNIA HAS LOST OVER 50,000
PEOPLE TO DRUG OVERDOSE
POISONING IN THE LAST FIVE YEAR
PERIOD. CALIFORNIA DRUG DEATHS
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS HAVE
MORE THAN DOUBLED, GROWING BY
117. ONE OF THE CHALLENGES IS
THAT, AMAZINGLY, IS THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL, MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE STILL NOT AWARE
OF THE DANGERS OF FENTANYL, IN
PARTICULAR THE DANGERS OF
FENTANYL BEING LACED WITH OTHER
DRUGS. ACCORDING TO A STUDY. IN
RECENT YEARS, ONLY 40% OF YOUNG
AMERICANS AND 31% OF TEENS
CONSIDER THEMSELVES
KNOWLEDGEABLE AS TO THE DANGERS
OF FENTANYL. IN RESPONSE TO OUR
EFFORTS HERE IN SACRAMENTO TO
ADDRESS FENTANYL POISONING, I'VE
COME INTO CONTACT WITH A NUMBER
OF PARENTS WHO HAVE LOST
CHILDREN. FOR EXAMPLE, JASON
ABNEY DIED FROM FENTANYL IN
PERCOCET HE HAD PURCHASED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. KYLE SMITH PASSED
AWAY FROM FAKE XANAX. CHARLIE
TIERNAN WAS WEEKS AWAY FROM
GRADUATING FROM COLLEGE. HE DIED
OF FENTANYL POISONING, TAKING A
COUNTERFEIT PILL. AND OF COURSE,
ALEXANDRA CAPELOUTO, WHO
BELIEVED THAT SHE WAS PURCHASING
OXYCODONE, TURNED OUT SHE DIED
FROM FENTANYL POISONING. SCR 119
PROCLAIMS MAY 7TH AS FENTANYL
AWARENESS DAY TO SUPPORT THE
INCREASING RESPONSIBILITY ON OUR
PART TO RAISE AWARENESS OF THE
DANGERS OF FENTANYL, I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM, SENATOR NGUYEN? THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 119, WHICH DECLARES
MAY 7TH, 2024 AS NATIONAL
FENTANYL AWARENESS. SADLY, WE
ARE ALL TOO AWARE OF THE DANGERS
AND DESTRUCTION THAT THIS HAS
BEEN CAUSED THAT HAS BEEN CAUSED
BY FENTANYL ACROSS OUR STATE AND
OUR COUNTRY. IN MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA, INCLUDING
MINE IN ORANGE COUNTY, WE HEAR
THE STORIES OF HEARTBREAK,
HEARTBREAKS AND SADNESS AT THE
LOSS OF MOMS, DADS, SONS AND
DAUGHTERS TO THIS LETHAL
SUBSTANCE. AND MY HEART HURTS
FOR THESE FAMILIES. ORANGE
COUNTY HAS REPORTED OVER 634
FENTANYL OR OPIATE RELATED
DEATHS SINCE 2022. LAST YEAR, I
HELD NUMEROUS TOWN HALLS AND
COMMUNITY MEETINGS THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT AND MET MANY OF THE
FAMILIES WHO'VE BEEN IMPACTED
AND DEVASTATED BY FENTANYL.
ILLICIT FENTANYL AND OTHER
ILLICIT SUBSTANCES HAVE NO PLACE
IN OUR SOCIETY AND CERTAINLY
HAVE NO PLACE IN THE HANDS OF
OUR CHILDREN OR OUR OTHER
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS.
THANKFULLY, AFTER THE MANY
RECENT LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES AND MYSELF, WE ARE
NOW GETTING TOUGH ON HOW TO
ADDRESS AND COMBAT COMBAT THIS
CRISIS. BUT MORE WORK NEEDS TO
BE DONE IN MEMORY OF THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN LOST TO THE EPIDEMIC.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DALLI. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS. I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SCR 119. I'D
LIKE TO JUST TAKE A MOMENT. I
HAVE ABOUT 5 OR 6 FACTS HERE
THAT I THINK ARE VERY IMPORTANT.
FENTANYL POISONING IS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH FOR YOUNG
ADULTS IN THE US, SURPASSING
SUICIDE AND GUN VIOLENCE AND CAR
ACCIDENTS. MORE MUST BE DONE TO
DETER THE SALE AND TRAFFICKING
OF THESE DEADLY DRUGS. IN 2021
ALONE, FENTANYL CLAIMED THE
LIVES OF MORE THAN 5700
CALIFORNIANS. BEHIND EACH OF
THOSE NUMBERS IS A STORY AND A
LIFE CUT SHORT. BETWEEN 2019 AND
2021, FENTANYL OVERDOSES AND
POISONING DEATHS AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE AGED 14 TO 18 MORE THAN
TRIPLED IN 2022, THE DRUG
ENFORCEMENT ADMINISTRATION
SEIZED OVER 10,000 POUNDS OF
FENTANYL POWDER AND MORE THAN 50
MILLION COUNTERFEIT FENTANYL
LACED PRESCRIPTION PILLS. NEARLY
500 CALIFORNIANS ARE DYING EVERY
MONTH FROM FENTANYL 500. WE ALL
KNOW A FAMILY OR FRIENDS THAT
HAVE BEEN AFFECTED BY FENTANYL
OVERDOSES IN CALIFORNIA IN 2022,
28,765 POUNDS OF FENTANYL WERE
SEIZED IN CALIFORNIA, ENOUGH TO
KILL THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
NORTH AMERICA TWICE NOW, MEMBERS
LAST YEAR, THE GOOD SENATOR THAT
BROUGHT THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD
HAD A BILL ALEXANDRIA'S LAW. AND
WE DIDN'T. WE 20 OVER 20 MEMBERS
WERE COAUTHORS TO THAT BILL. AND
WHAT DID WE DO? WE DIDN'T GET IT
OUT OF HERE. WE DIDN'T WE DIDN'T
STOP THE FLOW OF FENTANYL TO OUR
STATE. THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
YUCAIPA, MYSELF AND THE PRO TEM,
SAT DOWN TOGETHER FOR THREE
WEEKS AT A TIME TRYING TO GET A
WORKING GROUP. THAT'S THE BEST
WE CAN DO IN CALIFORNIA IS A
WORKING GROUP. WHEN WE HAVE 500
CALIFORNIANS A MONTH DYING, IT'S
PATHETIC. WE OUGHT TO BE ASHAMED
OF OURSELVES FOR NOT DOING MORE
TO CURB THIS. IF THIS WAS GUN
VIOLENCE OR IF THIS WAS A PLANE,
TWO PLANES A MONTH, OR WOULD
CRASH AND KILL THIS AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE, WE WOULD BE DOING MORE.
SENATOR DALLA, WE'RE GOING TO
ASK YOU TO STATE TO THE TOPIC OF
THE. I AM TALKING ABOUT THE
TOPIC. I'M TALKING ABOUT WHAT
FENTANYL DOES TO CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND ASK THIS BODY TO DO MORE FOR
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIED IN
CALIFORNIA DUE TO FENTANYL
DEATHS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
DURAZZO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SCR 119 WITH A FOCUS
ON INCREASED ACCESS TO TREATMENT
. THE SENATE'S WORKING TOGETHER
FOR A SAFER CALIFORNIA IS THE
BEST AND MOST THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO THE FENTANYL CRISIS.
WE NEED AN APPROACH THAT
INCLUDES ARREST AND PROSECUTION,
BUT ALSO TREATMENT AND INVESTING
RESOURCES TO END THE CAUSE OF
THE ADDICTION CRISIS. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PUBLIC HEALTH
DATA FIND THAT WHILE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN FEDERAL PRISON FOR
DRUG OFFENSES INCREASED FROM
25,000IN 1980 TO NEARLY 300,000
IN 2018, IT DIDN'T LEAD TO A
SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN DRUG USE
LAST YEAR. THE AVERAGE FEDERAL
TRAFFICKING PRISON SENTENCE FOR
FENTANYL RELATED SUBSTANCES WAS
ABOUT SIX AND A HALF YEARS. 56%
OF THOSE CONVICTED BLACK, 25%
HISPANIC. WE MUST LOOK AT THE
DISPARITIES IN OUR SYSTEM THAT
COULD RESULT IN ANOTHER FAILED
WAR ON DRUGS. THE QUESTION WE
NEED TO BE ASKING AND SOLVING IS
HOW DO WE ACTUALLY SAVE LIVES?
WHAT WILL WORK TO SAVE LIVES,
INCLUDING MORE RESOURCES AND
TREATMENT SERVICES, MEDICATIONS
FOR ADDICTION PREVENTION, AND
EARLY INTERVENTION ARE PART OF
THAT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM? HEARING
SEEING NONE. SENATOR UMBERG,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS
FENTANYL IS A SCOURGE AND IT
REQUIRES AN ALL IN APPROACH. LAW
ENFORCEMENT TREATMENT,
EDUCATION, PREVENTION,
DETERRENCE, ALL THOSE THINGS.
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT THE MOST
IMPORTANT IS PREVENTION AND
PREVENTION. THE MOST IMPORTANT
ELEMENT IS EDUCATION. AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS ELEVATING
THE KNOWLEDGE OF CALIFORNIANS AS
TO THE THREAT AND THE DANGERS OF
FENTANYL, EITHER TAKEN AS
FENTANYL OR LACED WITH OTHER
DRUGS, I URGE, AND I VOTE THANK
YOU, SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. AYE ALVARADO. GILL.
AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD. AYE DURAZO I
ADRIN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR.
AYE. MIN. NEWMAN AYE. NGUYEN.
AYE. NILO. AYE OKOBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE.
SKINNER I SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. AYE AYES
36. NO. ZERO. THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED NOW. MEMBERS WE'RE
MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. NOW WOULD BE THE TIME
FOR ANY MEMBER WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATE BILL
948 1146 994 1169 1405 933,
1009, 1099, 1145, 1158, 1168,
1252, 1329, 1336, 1394, 1427,
1476, 1518, 1521, 15, 22, 1524,
1526, 1527, 15, 28, 1529, 1530.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
140. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 137 171. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN AYE,
I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CORTEZ AYE. DALLI. AYE. DODD
AYE. DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. HURTADO AYE. JONES. AYE.
LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN. AYE. MCGUIRE
MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN NEWMAN. AYE.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO AYE. OKOBO AYE.
PADILLA PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH.
AYE RUBIO. AYE. SATO. AYE
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN. AYE. UMBERG AYE. WAHAB
AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK AYE. AYES
36 NOES ZERO. ON THE CONSENT.
AYES 36 NOES ZERO. ON THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. NOW,
MEMBERS, WE'RE MOVING TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
MENGIBAR, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE ON
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES WILL
MEET IN ROOM 1215 MINUTES AFTER
SESSION. BUDGET SUB THREE WILL
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION. SENATOR
WIENER BUDGET SUB FOUR IS
CANCELED. BUDGET SUB FOUR IS
CANCELED. NOW WE'RE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME FOR OUR
ADJOURN AND MEMORIES.
ADJOURNMENT AND MEMORIES.
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL IS UP.
SENATOR ALVARADO GIL, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY IN
MEMORY OF JOHN G. FRANZIA WHO
WAS A CO-FOUNDER OF BRONCO WINE
COMPANY OF MODESTO, ONE OF THE
LARGEST WINE COMPANIES IN THE
WORLD. HE PASSED OVER AT THE AGE
OF 84, IN COMPANY OF HIS FAMILY,
JOHN FRANZIA STUDIED ENOLOGY,
THE SCIENCE OF WINEMAKING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, DAVIS,
AND BEFORE THAT HE SPENT HIS
CHILDHOOD LEARNING EVERY ASPECT
OF THE WINEMAKING BUSINESS FROM
HIS PARENTS AND HIS GRANDPARENTS
. HE LEARNED ABOUT VITICULTURE
BUSINESS AT HIS FAMILY'S
VINEYARDS PLANTED THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, SEEN FIRSTHAND
THE RESULT OF HARD WORK AND THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM. ACTUALIZING
THE FRANZIA FAMILY HAD BEEN IN
THE WINE MAKING BUSINESS SINCE
THE 1800S, AND THE BRONCO WINE
IS STILL THE LARGEST PRIVATELY
HELD VINEYARD THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. THE PLANT IS OPERATING
SOUTH OF CERES IN STANISLAUS
COUNTY, AND IT OPENED IN 1973.
THIS COMPANY EMPLOYS ABOUT 750
PEOPLE YEAR ROUND AND OVER 250
MORE DURING THE HARVEST AND
CRUSH. IT HAS BUILT ITS OWN
BOTTLING PLANT IN NAPA AND
ACQUIRED WINEMAKING OPERATIONS
NEAR ESCALON AND MADERA IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. JOHN FRANZIA WAS
A FARMER AT HEART, AND HE
BELIEVED THAT THE GREATEST WINES
BEGAN WITH EXCEPTIONAL FAMILY
CENTERED VINEYARDS. HIS LEGACY
FOCUSED ON HIGH QUALITY WINES AT
AFFORDABLE RATE FOR BUYERS SUCH
AS THE QUIRKY TWO BUCK CHUCK,
WHICH WAS CREATED AND
POPULARIZED BY HIS COUSIN AND
BRONCO KHÓ FOUNDER FRED FRANZIA.
THE BRONCO FOUNDERS AND THE
FRANZIA FAMILY HAVE DEEP ROOTS
IN THE LOCAL AGRICULTURE AND
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY OF
CALIFORNIA. NOT ONLY IS
WINEMAKERS, BUT PRODUCERS AND
GLASS ARTISANS. JOHN IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE, MARILYN, OF 62
YEARS, FOUR CHILDREN, NINE
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO SISTERS. I
ASK THAT TODAY WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU. ON THE BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE,
WE EXTEND OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND WE ASK THAT YOU
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE CAN
BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. NEXT
UP IS SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT. AND
MEMBERS, TODAY I RISE IN THE
MEMORY OF A LONGTIME CALIFORNIA
EDUCATOR FITTING THAT WE TALK
ABOUT EDUCATION TODAY, DON
SHALVEY. DON SHELBY, KNOWN AS
ONE OF THE MOST CHEERFUL
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA. I WAS
AN EDUCATOR AND THE GODFATHER OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
MOVEMENT. DON WAS THE ONLY CHILD
BORN TO FLORENCE AND VINCENT
SCHIAVELLI IN SOUTH PHILADELPHIA
IN 1946, AND AFTER HIS DAD DIED
SUDDENLY, HE HAD TO GIVE UP HIS
DREAMS OF GOING TO MIT AND
STAYED TO TAKE CARE OF HIS MOM.
GETTING A DEGREE AT LA SALLE,
AND THEN GOING ON AND GETTING A
MASTER'S LATER AT GONZAGA AND A
EVENTUALLY A DOCTORATE AT USC.
HE WAS APPOINTED, WAS AN
EDUCATOR, A COUNSELOR, A MENTOR,
A SUPERINTENDENT. IN 1992, AS A
SUPERINTENDENT IN SAN CARLOS,
DON SPONSORED THE FIRST CHARTER
SCHOOL IN CALIFORNIA, THE SAN
CARLOS CHARTER LEARNING CENTER,
AND IN 1998, DON AND REED
HASTINGS STARTED A GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT THAT FOUNDED THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOL
MOVEMENT, AND HE FOUNDED THAT
SAME YEAR HE FOUNDED ASPIRE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN, IN, IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY, WHERE HE SERVED
AS CEO UNTIL 2009. ASPIRE
OPERATES 36 SCHOOLS ALL UP AND
DOWN THE VALLEY AND THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA, EDUCATING MORE THAN
11,000 STUDENTS, DON WAS A
GALVANIZING FORCE IN NATIONAL
EFFORTS TO FIND SOLUTIONS TO THE
COUNTRY'S MOST DIFFICULT
EDUCATION PROBLEMS. HE WAS AN
INAUGURAL MEMBER OF THE
ANNENBERG SUPERINTENDENT
LEADERSHIP FORUM, THE
PRESTIGIOUS COHORT, THE ASPEN
GLOBAL LEADERSHIP NETWORK, AND A
RECIPIENT OF THE ASHOKA
FELLOWSHIP. HIS FATHER, VINCENT,
HAD BEEN A TRUMPET PLAYER PLAYER
AND PASSED ON HIS LOVE OF MUSIC
TO DON, WHO WAS CONSTANTLY
TAPPING HIS, HIS SADDLE SHOES TO
SOME REMEMBERED TUNE, AND WITH
BOOMBOX AND MICROPHONE. HE WAS
ALWAYS THE EMCEE WITH THE
PLAYLIST, OFTEN INCLUDING DARYL
HALL AND JOHN OATES WERE
STANDARDS FOR EVERY SCHOOL EVENT
GOING AWAY, PARTY STAFF, GOODBYE
AT WEDDINGS AND FUNERALS. THE
LAST TWO DECADES, DON HAS LIVED
ON A RANCH WITH HIS WIFE AND
FELLOW EDUCATOR SUE IN LINDEN.
IN MY DISTRICT, WITH HIS SON
BRIAN, A FORMER NAVY SEAL. HE
LEAVES BEHIND HIS DAUGHTER
MEGAN, ALSO AN EDUCATOR. HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER, GRACE, AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BROTHER IN LAW,
RETIRED SENATOR MIKE MACHADO,
HIS BROTHER GREG. MANY COUSINS,
AND OF COURSE, HIS WIFE, SUE,
DON ONCE SAID ABOUT SUE, SHE
MADE ME SO MUCH BETTER. AND
EVERYONE THAT KNOWS DON WOULD
SAY THE SAME THING ABOUT HIM,
DON WAS A REGENT AT, AT PACIFIC,
AND HE. IF I, IF I SHOWED UP AT
A MEETING THAT WAS ABOUT
EDUCATION AND DON SHELBY WAS
THERE, I KNEW IT WAS LEGIT,
THAT'S THE KIND OF GUY DON
SHELBY WAS A REAL LEADER IN
CALIFORNIA, STOCKTON WILL FOR
SOME, SOMEONE KING COUNTY WILL
MISS HIS HELP AND EXPERTISE AT
TRYING TO SOLVE THE TOUGHEST
PROBLEMS, HE WAS ALSO, HELPED
FOUND THE MELISSA AND BILL GATES
FOUNDATION AND WAS VERY ACTIVE
AS THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THEIR
EDUCATION TEAM, WE ASK THAT THE
SENATE WOULD ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY AND ALSO TO NOTE THAT
FORMER SENATOR MIKE MACHADO, HIS
DON'S WIFE, SUE, AND HIS BROTHER
ARE ALSO IN THE GALLERY WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU, SENATOR
ALVARADO. GIL. THANK YOU FROM
THE SENATOR FROM STOCKTON, FOR
ME, DON SHELBY WAS THE
GRANDFATHER OF EDUCATION EQUITY
FOR THE UNDERSERVED AREAS OF SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY AND ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. HE
CREATED OUR FIRST CHARTER SCHOOL
IN 1994. WHEN I WAS A BRAND NEW
COLLEGE STUDENT, JUST BLOSSOMING
AND WORKING IN SOME OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED AREAS OF RURAL
CALIFORNIA. MR. SHELBY WAS AN
ORGANIZER. HE WAS A STRATEGIST,
HE WAS A RANCHER, AND HE WAS A
MENTOR TO SO MANY YOUNG
EDUCATORS AS WELL AS PARENT
ADVOCATES. AND FOR OVER 25
YEARS, HE BUILT HIS CAREER
AROUND EXCELLENCE IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION. AND IT DIDN'T MATTER
WHETHER YOU WERE A TEACHER, AN
ASPIRING TEACHER AND
ADMINISTRATOR, A PARENT OR A
STUDENT, HE LOOKED AT YOU WITH
THE SAME APPRECIATION AND THE
SAME EYES OF YOU CAN DO, YOU CAN
DO IT ATTITUDE. THE LAST SEVEN
YEARS, HE WAS A CEO OF SAN
JOAQUIN A, WHICH WAS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT I WAS ABLE TO
WORK WITH TO LEARN MORE. MY
CRAFT IN BEING AN ADVOCATE FOR,
CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES. AND
ULTIMATELY HE INSPIRED ME TO
PURSUE MY APPOINTMENT, BY THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE ADVISORY
COMMISSION ON SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND ULTIMATELY BUILT THAT PATH
FOR ME TO SERVE HERE AS STATE
SENATOR OF SENATE DISTRICT FOUR.
IN 1999, SHELBY FOUNDED THE
FULL, FULL, FIRST MULTI-SCHOOL
CHARTER ORGANIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA, WAS THE CEO FOR A
DECADE. OAKLAND BASED ASPIRE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THESE SCHOOLS
ARE NOW WITHIN MY SENATE
DISTRICT, AND I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF BEING ABLE TO SEE
HIS DREAM FROM THE GROUND UP AND
MEET WITH SOME OF THE STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES THAT KNOW THE DON
SHELBY NAME. BUT PERHAPS DON'T
KNOW THE FULL EXTENT OF HIS
HISTORY. HE WAS A TUTOR WHO SET
HIGH EXPECTATIONS, GUIDING MANY
PUBLIC SCHOOL LEADERS IN THEIR
CAREERS, WHO WENT ON TO OPEN
THEIR OWN HIGH EXCELLENT PUBLIC
AWARD WINNING CHARTER SCHOOLS.
HE WAS INSTRUMENTAL IN PASSING
TWO STATE LAWS THAT ENABLED
CHARTER SCHOOLS TO EXPAND THEIR
REACH AND STRENGTHEN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PARTNERSHIP
WITH LOCAL TRADITIONAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. HE ENCOURAGED MANY
PEOPLE, SUCH AS MYSELF, WHO WERE
PARENTS, TO RUN FOR SCHOOL
BOARDS AND TO SERVE IN ELECTED
OFFICE WHEN MANY OF US,
PARTICULARLY FIRST GEN OR
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
LEARNERS, ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE LEARNERS, DID NOT SEE
OURSELVES AS REPRESENTATIVES OF
AN ELECTED OFFICE, BUT HE DID
ENCOURAGE US TO PURSUE THOSE
SCHOOL BOARD SEATS. I WANT TO
THANK DON SHELBY FOR HIS SHOE
FASHION AND THANK HIM FOR THE
KARAOKE SONGS, AND TO THANK HIM
MOST OF ALL FOR SEEING BEYOND
WHAT WAS POSSIBLE IN PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND SEEING THE
PERSEVERANCE IN SO MANY, SUCH AS
MYSELF, TO FORGE THROUGH
SEEMINGLY INSURMOUNTABLE,
INSURMOUNTABLE BARRIERS AND TO
GIVE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT
VOICE AND TO GIVE US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE WHAT IS
OUR GREATEST POTENTIAL, OUR
HOPES AND OUR DREAMS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE SEND
OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO THE
SHELBY FAMILY AND APPRECIATE ALL
THE CONTRIBUTIONS. AND WE ASK
THAT YOU BRING YOUR NAME FORWARD
SO HE COULD BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED. OUR NEXT ADJOURN
IN MEMORY IS BY SENATOR GONZALES
. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF BELOVED FIGURE
IN THE LONG BEACH COMMUNITY,
JEANETTE RAMIREZ, WHO WAS KILLED
BY A STRAY BULLET HE FONDLY WAS
KNOWN AS THE CORN GUY OR THE
ELOTE GUY. HE WIENER HAD SERVED
THE WRIGLEY NEIGHBORHOOD OF LONG
BEACH WITH CORN AND SHAVED ICE
FOR THE PAST 14 YEARS. GINA'S
PRESENCE BECAME A BEACON OF
KINDNESS IN THE COMMUNITIES HE
SERVED. HE WAS ALWAYS EAGER TO
LEND A HAND AND SHARE A MOMENT
OF JOY WITH THE PEOPLE HE
CROSSED PATHS WITH, AND STUDENTS
LINED UP AFTER SCHOOL TO TASTE
TRADITIONAL LATINO CANDIES AND
TREATS, AND FAMILIES LOOKED
FORWARD TO GREETING HIM AT LOCAL
PARKS. HE WAS A LOVING FATHER OF
TWO WHO WORKED TIRELESSLY TO
PROVIDE FOR HIS FAMILY. ON HIS
FREE TIME, YAHNER ENJOYED
PLAYING SOCCER AND FRIENDS AT
LOCAL PARKS, AND HIS LOSS IS
FELT DEEPLY BY HIS LOVING WIFE
OF 16 YEARS AGAIN. HIS TWO YOUNG
CHILDREN AND THE ENTIRE LONG
BEACH COMMUNITY WHO'VE COME
TOGETHER TO MEMORIALIZE HIM AND
FINANCIALLY SUPPORT HIS FAMILY.
I RESPECT THAT WE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN HIS
MEMORY AND OFFER OUR SINCEREST
CONDOLENCES TO THE RAMIREZ
FAMILY. THANK YOU. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE, WE
EXTEND OUR DEEPEST CONDOLENCES
AND ASK THAT YOU BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE, TOO, CAN BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS. SENATOR
GONZALES, THE DESK IS CLEAR.
YES, MR. PRESIDENT, THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY, MAY 13TH, 2024 AT 2 P.M.
THANK YOU. THE SENATE WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 3:30 P.M, AT WHICH
TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE. WE'LL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY, MAY 13TH AT 2 P.M.